uh this was during the time that her she
told me that they were separated right
and i said well what is one of the
biggest factors why you want to leave
like what's going on like
what what in your relationship is so bad
she goes honestly like sexually i'm not
attracted to him
and he has a micropedic and i was like
hey man don't be kissing this guy like
that
and i didn't know that micropenis was an
actual medical term like he
has a microscopic penis
like you got to get that [ __ ] diamond
jeweler in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast we have nick the ear here
nte tron is that what it says on your
t-shirt
trump trump strong trump nte strong
isn't that legible so i would definitely
redesign that i went to chick-fil-a and
i
bought and the guy saw my shirt and was
like oh like have you seen the lance
armstrong documentary and i didn't know
he was he thought
my shirt said lipstick and i go no
is it good he's like yeah you should
check it out i think you'd really like
it and i was like oh thanks man
he's like yeah i have a good one i drove
off i was like why the [ __ ] did he and i
looked down and i was like oh
who made that shirt did you make that
shirt yeah my graphic designer made it
for me
and what is he five i'm sorry i don't
know you guys i'm so sorry i apologize
that actually was very offensive and i
don't know you and you
it sucks but hey this is my brand david
you're ruining my
brand that's cool yeah that's fair yeah
you should redo that though
why don't you tell me that huh well i
couldn't read it because it looks like
[ __ ]
yeah it's off the edge
the s is the issue dude yeah yeah well
if you like the shirt off and just wear
a little bit yeah just because it looks
like a vietnamese person's lashes
sweating shirtless strong
you're you're wrong it's strong oh
really you didn't say that at first
though
what were you saying so we have pat
llama
i'm actually going to start trying to
learn japanese and spanish i'm trying to
figure out which one first
let's let's learn spanish together come
on let's go do spanish you're in la baby
all right let's do it let's do it hey
and then afterwards and once we master
the
podcast in spanish dog if i could speak
spanish fluently
i'm leaving mariel right now and getting
me a mamacita yeah mama
i gotta go over your mom yeah
well she's she's salvadorian that
doesn't count i yeah
i want the one from east la that has
super thin eyebrows
oh yes and also is this close to
punching me in my mouth every time
minus the eyebrows she was born in east
l.a she was born in isles i dated a
couple of those
oh what's that like dude yeah it was
fiery pretty fun
almost died
or what yeah get the [ __ ] out of here i
[ __ ] love you
what what do you want stay here but
[ __ ] be with me and get out of here
he's emotionally i was like did you know
my ex-girlfriend yeah yeah
so what about your east la connect uh uh
i want to say her name because it's just
a funny name but i don't want to say her
name
but uh it was just stephanie
yeah it was one of those names you know
what i mean it was um
i literally almost said her name it was
she was from commerce
uh she was i was young that was like 14.
and she used to take the bus to like
come visit me and [ __ ] and she ended up
beating the [ __ ] out of this other girl
that i hooked up with too
and because she was on down down yeah
she like [ __ ] this girl up back
and i felt really bad and i was like
what did you find attractive about her
was it the threats
well we met on myspace and i was a
virgin and i didn't want to be a virgin
anymore
and this girl was would come over and
have sex with me and
i was like were you older than you were
same age i think we were the same age
had a belly button ring and [ __ ] she
came to you [ __ ] the temperature sean
paul temperature we used to blast out of
my room
[Laughter]
did wrong
and just but yeah she [ __ ] somebody up
and it was just all bad i was 14. you
don't know [ __ ] when you're 14 bro i was
like
hey she was just like [ __ ] and
fighting dude [ __ ] and fighting what
in the hell
why would she just start beating up
girls for it was your ex-girlfriend yeah
so i it was a girl i was
i was dating her and then i kind of like
had a thing with another girl
and that she like kind of approved
though she was like you can kiss her
i remember her telling me that i was
like like whatever
and then she bring her back home she was
mad that i kissed her like with her not
there
and then she ended up beating this
girl's ass that's so weird that's
confusing you were
two steps away from having an open
relationship when you were fortunate you
could have had a threesome jackass
i could have i didn't know what's wrong
with you dude i was not
i didn't know she literally said you can
like kiss her in front of me
and then maybe if you like bender over
in front of me yeah
that's gay yeah
it was actually pretty chill she took it
like a [ __ ] whip
she we said ah the first time we had sex
i was at a buddy's back house i was like
hey dude like i think i'm gonna have sex
can i like
no one is your parents aren't home he's
like yeah just use my back house and we
just had sex it was awkward
but it was chill yeah i didn't come but
it was cool
black dude yeah it's great let me tell
you something first time i had sex
i came immediately yeah she didn't even
expect it
i didn't expect it nobody expected it
wasn't even as soon as it went in just
one stroke just
i just remember the first time it went
in i was like this is very warm
i was like it's very changeable hot
the temperature is very rubbered up you
were in a rubber absolutely not
really for your first time adventurous
wow
i did that was the only time i wore them
it was just in the heat of the moment
and i was like you know where condoms no
i do i do shut up shut up man
and either way i knew i didn't have aids
because
i was a virgin nice so we're all safe
here
yeah was she a virgin i don't know usual
transactions i didn't really think he
really had sex with the virus aids
i was like listen if you give me ages
you guys stay with me for life so either
way that's tight i win
and that's how you lock a girl down yeah
mm-hmm give her guilt
you could have killed me or a baby
usually yeah they call anchor babies put
a baby in yeah
yeah it kind of hurt when i went inside
too i remember when it pulled the skin
back a little bit this is more i like
that morgan freeman
are we in shock it was the day in the
dawn
you know why because david got a piece
on him you do huh i do not have
i have a very uh because on the beam
i always do it calls it a clay pocket
it's like
it's like excuse me yeah
hooked up with somebody whose previous
partner had a micro penis
no that's so she probably came like god
that [ __ ] bums me out bro
yeah that makes me sad too so cause i'm
like two inches away from that yeah
if i repeated the story if i repeated
this story i'm sorry new listeners will
love this story
but i was hooking up with this girl
that actually taught me how to shoot
photos so i didn't know how to use a
dslr at the time
and i met her through somebody else so
this girl
actually was when we were hooking up
she was going through a separation and a
divorce from her husband right so she
had a kid or whatever right
she was really cute lady had ass and
titties
oh fantastic oh wow double combo listen
we were like backward forward and
backward sorry guys
i started slapping her titties in half i
didn't know what to do with it
you put on a lazy susan you just spin
her yeah so she
at the time it was i thought that she
was separated with her husband
she actually wasn't so she kind of like
lied to me i didn't know no she just
lied to you
yeah she lied to me so i didn't know
right and it was funny because
so she told me this story where uh this
was during the time that her she told me
that they were separated right and i
said what was one of the biggest factors
why you want to leave like what's going
on like what what in your relationship
is so bad she goes honestly like
sexually i'm not attracted to him
and he has a micro penis and i was like
hey man don't be dissing this guy like
that
come
he on a micro penis and i didn't know
that micro penis was an actual medical
term
like he has a microscopic penis
like you got to get that [ __ ] diamond
jeweler glass like and like look at that
yeah so this is what we did so we were
at a starbucks and we were chopping it
up
i had a starbucks cup i had a straw and
i pulled it all the way out i was like
you stopped me at the length of his
penis right and i went super down as a
joke right and she goes
further down i'm like what and i kid you
not it was like like an inch and a half
at most
she was that is the size of his penis
she shocked me to the
[ __ ] universe i was like what is it i
looked at what a micro penis was and i
guess
it's like an inch and a half to two
inches that's a micro penis and when
david gets into something and you reach
researches something he goes [ __ ] i
go
in i go micro penis deep dude crazy hit
it's literally like that damn that bums
me out yeah so she was talking sucks but
just to go on to this story
when we hooked up let me tell you
something yeah this woman treated my
penis like it was oh boy
let's go it was so funny because she was
treating my penis as if it was the
largest thing on earth and i'm like whoa
i'm like let me tell you something girl
this [ __ ] average is [ __ ] but you
making me feel like okay wow
she's like oh my god not too hard you
want to hear the most [ __ ] up
situation about this so
this is actually right before i was
going to move to l.a and so she knew
this
right and we were hooking up we weren't
going to be in a relationship
and just that dad especially when i
found out through our other friend
because she asked me she goes hey are
you hooking up with this girl right
and i'm like no good like you why'd you
say because i met her through her
i don't want to dance
seven times before i have a sex with
your friend
but i uh so she was like oh good because
you know
you know she's still married to the guy
and i'm like oh wow
i had no idea and i'm like oh my god i'm
a homeworker
well she she eventually did break up
with him but i felt weird
having sex with a woman that has a kid
and that she's married i didn't know
about this stuff
but lo and behold so we hooked up a
couple more times after that because the
guilt wasn't that strong
because the boy was wrecking shots so i
[ __ ] you [ __ ] not
she she hits me up how's david oh this
is like
a day or two before i'm about to leave
she sends me a text
of a pregnancy test oh [ __ ] you pharoah
of a princess said she goes number one
i'm late and it says that i'm pregnant
and you
you're probably most likely dead because
i haven't hooked up with anybody else
besides
and the first thing i wrote back was
like [ __ ]
i wrote [ __ ] that's why david went
to l.a
and living so yeah where's your son bro
this is
no and so so the reason why i knew for a
hundred percent
because those two times that we hooked
up after so the first time we smashed
had a condom the other two times
i had what we called guilty dick because
i was hooking up with her
after i found out that she was still
with the dude before i called it off
i'm pretty sure you guys think really
low of me right now but i was very young
at the time
whatever and then no one's here to judge
i knew for a fact number one
your boy didn't come or nut at all i
just couldn't do it like i just was out
of it
yeah so i just really couldn't do it
there it is david is a that pure of a
human being good guy i was just going
over it
like have you ever been inside a vagina
and your dick just slightly goes soft
yeah right here all the time with it
never happened to me i was like this is
just never going to happen
and i was like this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was like you're lying right now
because she knew i was going to leave la
and so like lo and behold i'm like okay
well how about we go in together
and then we'll find out right and then
she just wrote she just kind of goes
radio silent for a little bit she comes
back oh it turns out it's not real and
i'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] wow
you [ __ ] psycho she was gonna trap
you though she was trying she was trying
to trap me to stay in sacramento
whatever what if her husband really
doesn't have a micro penis
oh i mean cool if he didn't then your
boy got a big ol dog
she just had a micro penis for a very
long time oh man micropenis is a bunch
she tried to keep me in sacramento
that's [ __ ] bananas psycho you were a
[ __ ] psychopath dude and lo and
behold that was the last
filipino girl i've ever dated damn dude
two times i dated somebody that was
filipino that pulled crazy [ __ ] on me
you know what i just said what what else
is that like david's a homewrecker so i
don't want to be associated with that
i'm leaving now
i am not a home wrecker no no you you're
all right he was no the home was already
wrecked i just went to go salvage some
parts and he's worth sweeping up a
little bit sorry i just don't know
yeah dude have you ever been to mexico
mission trips where you helped clean up
the home
exactly that's me and then yeah he built
the frame i went to
life you were doing the lord's work yeah
the tsunami hit japan and i was just
creating up a little bit
[Music]
legit though she was very very pretty
and cute i miss her sometimes
yeah that's the thing about like with
girls like they could be crazy but if
the sex was good you're like [ __ ] man
like
that's how like sex driven dudes are is
that we'll be like damn i still miss her
though
it probably goes by [ __ ] trying to
stab me i'm sure girls like you know you
always hear about girls with like crazy
ass dudes that are just like
like they're full of [ __ ] and then like
they're they're always treating them bad
but they give good
dick though but do they got a good dick
they got good there
yeah and i guarantee you mine was quite
mediocre but she enjoyed it
yeah whatever dude now let me tell you
something your boy a lazy [ __ ] dude
sometimes i just lay back i smoke a
blunt and i see what happens
and i wake up i'm like you nut she goes
but you did i don't remember
your buddy was sleep that's what
happened speaking of japanese i saw
something interesting on the news
recently actually marielle sent me this
tara's house
oh this full is [ __ ] into territory i
just started watching tara's house
it's called terrorist house terrorist
house it's about a group it's a reality
show of like
this podcast is brought to you by md
acne my friends if you're
anything like me you assume that when
you hit that magical number 18 all your
skin problems were going to go away well
guess what dummies we were
wrong taking care of our skin and having
it look nice
is work but it doesn't have to be if you
get
md acne my friends md
acne's app eliminates these problems by
analyzing our skin
and delivering effective customized acne
treatment products with unlimited
dermatology support with free fine
tuning and product formulations
so you're not stuck with something that
doesn't work
yeah that's super important it's pretty
simple all you have to do
is download the md acne app it will
analyze your skin in a matter of seconds
and deliver a complete kit of customized
acne medication
cleanser and moisturizer that's all
tailored to
what your skin needs also the first
month supply is for free and all you
have to do is pay for shipping
so just go to mdacne.combrain to
download the md acne app analyze your
skin and get your first
month's supply for free and all you have
to do once again is just pay
for shipping listen i love this stuff my
skin is clear
so once again to get good skin
and a month free supply go to md
acne.com
brain and just pay for shipping uh
japanese people and they all
you know how he always describes [ __ ] it
just sounds terrible yeah don't ever try
to sell a show
so richard ramirez is the night stalker
you [ __ ] so there's a guy he's called
the japan
twitter killer takahiro shiraishi
sentenced to death so this fool would
find his victims through twitter and i
guess like these people on twitter
they were already suicidal so in his
mind i think he was
i think he was doing them a favor you're
like japanese [ __ ] ever
let me help you like even their
circulars in japan are just like very
courteous yeah they're like trying to
help you out yeah they're still doing
like like community service yeah yeah
like they're still having people
they're very polite about their murder
so takahiro used twitter to lure
suicidal women to his home
saying he could help them die and in
some cases
claimed he would kill himself alongside
them he strangled and dismembered
eight women okay never mind i take
everything out that i said
and he dis [ __ ] membered them dude
wow strike that from the record yeah
saying he also uh from uh
and one man aged 15 to 26 between august
and october
in 2017 said japan's kyoto's new agency
crazy you know the shows that you could
build a fan base is it through anything
do anything there's a niche for
everybody
so he would he would just say hey you
want to kill yourself like once you come
over here we'll kill
ourselves together yeah so he was
finding people who were already on the
verge of
because i heard like japan's suicide
rate is so high like there's
like more suicide what do you think it
is well it's like
i mean if you guys don't know a lot
about like japanese and korean culture
like it's it's very there's a lot of
pride
and ego and on top of that too there's a
lot of
like societal pressure right that's why
they're the best at everything though
yeah i mean it's a very stressful world
i think it's a great place to visit
but for example like they have stuff
called cram schools right so the moment
you're in elementary school that your
destiny and life is already being made
at that moment wow so it travels with
you all the way through high school all
the way through college and grade school
so depending on what university you go
into that's gonna set where you're gonna
be in society the hierarchy of it right
um and this isn't like dated news this
is like stuff that i know from friends
who
still live in japan and they talk to me
about it and they think it's it was hard
for them when they had to do that
growing up
that's why they came over here the
states because it's a lot easier college
what they when my friend my one of my
korean friends told me he goes college
is actually
easier than uh grade school damn because
they have to go through
uh cram school and all this
extracurricular studying to make sure
that they get into really good colleges
but once they're in college it's a lot
easier than it ever was in elementary
school
so there's a lot of like the societal
pressure to be a certain way to behave a
certain way act a certain way that's why
you see like sometimes in japan
they have these things called like robot
cafes they get like go to these [ __ ]
bars they get to let loose
like you'll see in korea too i think
they stopped this now recently
but there was a competition almost to
like
if the boss doesn't leave we don't leave
even though it's time to clock out
so let's say like you're supposed to
clock out at like seven o'clock right
but the boss is still in his office
nobody's gonna leave they're gonna stay
there to make sure that they're not the
lazy person
wow so they'll wait until so the boss
can be there until like 12 a.m and then
on top of that the boss wants to go
drink you're gonna go out and drink it's
called heshik they're gonna go out and
drink with him
party it up come back into the office
work like that six seven days a week
yeah and then you can't look like the
[ __ ] bum so now i heard from a buddy
of mine who's in korea they're like
they're actually putting uh i think like
a
a rule that at certain like corporate
companies they have to shut off the
electricity in the building by like 10
pm
wow so even if like the boss wants to
stay behind to work
they don't have to feel the societal
pressure to go ahead and outwork
somebody else
yeah so there's just a lot of [ __ ] up
things that happens come to america
because they would [ __ ] make a
killing that's the opposite over yeah
that's like
the bosses you're [ __ ] the boss dude
dude like japan hr is just an old
grandpa just giving people the middle
finger
have you heard of a war that's what i've
been i remember there was a story about
well not story but like it's like a
known thing but like the the japanese
suicide forest where people just go in
there all the time and then just
yeah get lost and just kill themselves
that's the thing that uh the one of the
paul brothers recorded he reported
recorded a dead man hanging a [ __ ] he
thought it was a good idea wow that's
tight though
his apology was hilarious to me i didn't
know what i was doing
like bro this is the worst acting i've
ever seen in my life that's when he was
at his worst huh yeah and he kind of
like
stopped being that much of a [ __ ]
you know i guess he seems like yes he's
kind of likable
more likeable now than he did back then
because back then
everybody wanted to punch his [ __ ]
face yeah yeah now it's his brother that
they want to punch
yeah because compared to his brother
he's like oh logan paul is way better
than that [ __ ] guy
yeah but his brother took the mantle
yeah but definitely don't go into
like the suicide forest and like people
i mean no that's crazy
that's what dead bodies that's why so we
went into this
um one place in japan it was like this
uh
cafe rainforest cafe is what it was
called right
well we have some out here disneyland oh
no this is actually
this is this is a dude dressed up as a
woman
uh in like a mushroom costume and it's
like a cafe and he comes inside
and this dude i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not it
was me joe and a bunch of other jk
people and were in there and they it's a
rain
for there's a cafe you could actually
order stuff on like on like an
electronic pad or whatever
and i didn't expect to see a guy you
know cross-dressing for fun or whatever
that it is
he comes up he goes harl my name is a
nasty
i'm like what the [ __ ] did you just say
to me right now where are we
my name is a nesting mesti would you
like a
hippa seed
looking at this this japanese dude
looking at me telling me his name is
nasty and i
and i oh nasty my name is oh i thought
it was like nesty
oh wow okay i would love to have a seat
then i just sit in there and i don't
think he was amused
that i wasn't giving him the reaction
that he wanted like
oh this is so cool i just went
dave was like oh no i don't i do not
judge i'm not joking i was shocked yeah
that his name was nasty
this guy he was judging the whole time
listen you punched him in the face like
oh get away from me
you slacked him hey you didn't listen to
the story we actually made hot steaming
mushroom love
oh [ __ ] yeah wow yeah behind one of
those [ __ ] super mario mushrooms
we made sweet japanese korean love and
then we combined our countries together
and that's when baby toad came out like
from mario kart
and that's how you guys absolutely throw
up the rock
you know what i just [ __ ] find out i
heard [ __ ] um uh bj penn is arrested
again for [ __ ] their wedding
again yeah that's what they do bro like
ever since i came back from hawaii i
feel like i got that spirit
oh you got that now you know why he got
into a fight what happened i don't know
what happened i just saw the
picture he seems like he's just like
kind of lost without fighting
he's yeah he seems lost i feel like a
lot of fighters when they don't have
that outlet
it's just it's it's really hard for them
to like
readjust to like daily life because i
was actually looking at some old bj pen
videos
that dude was a he was the pinnacle of
the sport he was the conor mcgregor he
was like
the guy yeah and all of a sudden you
know as
years went by like he just kind of
slowly
declined which sucks because he's a
[ __ ] legend you know but now he's
just this guy that gets in bar fights
with people
that sucks bro that sucks but yeah it's
uh they need purpose bro
i mean and also like you think about the
highs and the highs of fighting like
that that
[ __ ] feeling of being on top of the
world the baddest dude in the world
like that just that rush of after you
get down with somebody and then like
now you're just at the grocery store
five days a week yeah you're like
[ __ ] i probably like that too so it's
like something drunk and [ __ ] again
damn dude [ __ ] man that's sad bro like
what are you what are you saying to this
guy dude it's like come on man
like you're gonna tell him to cut that
[ __ ] out he'll beat your ass
you can you can't it's like you just
that dude just needs purpose bro like
like that's that's what he lives on the
big island right yeah
did you see b japan was that you did you
fight with me yeah he beat my ass
would you start with bj penn if he asked
you to yeah but i probably you know what
it is though like when i spar with
people that i really like i'm a fans of
i turn into the biggest little [ __ ] and
i show them like two more is that why
you just [ __ ] suck alex in the face
like like no take your anger out on
alex's [ __ ]
dome his hairless face
his [ __ ] beardless face his blues
brother's face you know guys i'm not
going to sit here for this
okay this is ridiculous i know when i
support alex dude it's
i'm not like trying to knock him out or
anything oh yes he is yeah it looks like
you're
abusing somebody it looks like you're
taking out all your frustration all your
anger on you guys this podcast is for
entertainment purposes only
everything they're saying is [ __ ] not
true you are literally
beating up alex so bad he actually hit
me so hard the other day i cried
dig [ __ ]
he did the no look max holloway punch on
my face and i thought i'm the best boxer
and i thought he was joking and he
actually threw it at me and he connected
right to my face
i was like oh he's not gonna throw it i
was like oh laying down
bro it was like boop no
that's how soft it was whispered you
always say
it's so funny when you see the the the
switch flip in this dude too much bro
but it's true
dismembering people that are suicidal
alex for no reason am i next am i next
you are
thinking next i think alex is victim
number one
alex is going to be murdered why do you
hit him so hard i don't hit him hard bro
and you ask alex he's like
you don't hit me hard alex is not saying
alex is always like yo why nick would be
going [ __ ] on me
like i like him he's my friend and he's
just beating my [ __ ] ass all the time
alex no because alex wants to fight man
and he quits when
when we spar and it gets like when the
rounds get long he he doesn't quit but
like he gets tired and then he's like oh
[ __ ] i'm tired
but it's like no dude if you you when
you do the round you finish the round
no matter what yeah no you don't have to
push it dude yeah and that's all it is
it's just a little tough love
and alex could take my punches because
his head is the biggest thing i've ever
seen and his big
is thick so it doesn't move when i hit
him and i have baby hands bro i don't
[ __ ] hit her no
that's not true that's not true bro
that is not true yeah that's a lie i'm
laughing because
of david's laugh my detector has
determined that that is the last or if
you're on maury right now that was a
[ __ ] you're the father right now dude
yeah the camera bro you hit [ __ ] hard
that's why when we would spar i'd be
like i didn't i
was trying to figure out i was like i
don't know if nick naturally just has
heavy hands
or if he's just trying to hit me hard
but it wasn't always like that though it
wasn't always like that
no i i i i i it's just i'm not saying
that i was like
it was part of it was just part of i'm
not saying that it was like [ __ ] like i
hate you for it but i'm just saying i
was in my head while we were sparring
thinking
damn does he just have heavy ass hands
or does he have a couple years ago and
then i was like nick is a dick
i don't like him you were hitting him
like he was the oppressor yeah you were
you were hitting him slavery on my face
yeah i learned from the best savannah
young
yeah yeah our last episode for the
reference yeah
amazing slavery out of my face at you
with a rose taking
all that railroad [ __ ] [ __ ] out of my
face
all that dynamite railroad [ __ ] out of
my face with the ho chi minh uppercut
[ __ ]
that's what it is dude
take pride in your heavy hands you have
heavy hands nah dude anyway so like who
would be someone you would spar with
a great segway yeah fighting is only for
fighters
fighting is only for fighters nothing
not me i have no interest in fighting
you guys we always talk about this and i
don't want to fight either
with somebody not if you lit up crystal
said dude yeah
[ __ ] i didn't even before i was
i wasn't in the mindset of fighting i'm
glad i did it though it was fun as [ __ ]
you were literally like hey pat you i
mean hey
chris you okay like chris was mad that
you were asking if he was okay he was
mad
not mad but he was just like he's like
why is this guy asking me if i'm okay
after he punched me in the face
because i like chris bro i do like i
feel like that's more infuriating though
you know you punch me the face and then
see if i'm okay
yeah this one pat just started checking
his pulse during the middle of the fight
he took off his glove he went to his
neck he was like let me see
he pulls out a stethoscope and he's like
are you okay 120 over 80 he's good
third round
i love that [ __ ] i missed training so
[ __ ] much man i can't wait till
[ __ ] covert is over yeah it's never
going to be over
isn't there a new strain there's always
there's no strains bro
you know you know what that's a good
question what's your favorite strain of
covid go
um mine is the one that kills people
yeah
yeah yeah yeah insensitive [ __ ] but la
is reopening
oh [ __ ] like he's reopening though yeah
well [ __ ] knew someone's a little
knob bro like he knew some kind of
close everything down and was like all
right guys figure it out
and then now he's like all right we'll
open back up again and then it's like
all right there's nobody some kind of
whack after he got caught eating in the
[ __ ] restaurant i know
like bro what kind of [ __ ] is that bro
there's all this [ __ ] about gavin newsom
remember when he got his hair did
with nancy pelosi no yeah nancy it was
just nancy that was just nancy they're
all full of [ __ ] bro
all that that's just why i used to see
um because i gavin newsome i'm coming
for you
[ __ ] oh he's ready to fight the
fight bro for you david newsom that's
the challenge this is for all the small
businesses out there
you [ __ ] jerk
that's a good promo good promo hey man
you should
you should coach calvin kane on [ __ ]
talking hey you know what uh
if i'm [ __ ] if i'm the the freshman
you're [ __ ]
the professor so [ __ ] you because you're
old baby
yeah yeah yeah come on
you bring your best three i got my best
through right here i would like to see
you
honestly if it was nick dunn versus
gavin newsom in the ring three rounds i
would pay a lot of money to see that
does he have any boxing experience or
any training experience
i don't know it doesn't matter i think
he's connected to the mob though so good
luck
you might die after i take that all back
i'm sorry gavin you the man
gruesome newsome is what they call them
dude gruesome news why do they call them
that
because they [ __ ] hate them oh yeah
is that what they they call themselves
this one every time you go to like a
shooting range or a gun store it's
all fat banners of recall news
dude commie california monterey park
there's all these like old chinese
ladies that have their own stand that
says recall newsome and then in mandarin
they have it over it and they have
petitions ready to sign they're ready
everyone's everyone's sick of this fall
dude even asian people hate it because
huh yeah
this [ __ ] everyone because
they're forced to close down man it
sucks
before we continue this podcast this
podcast is brought to you
by babel the number one
language learning app hola my friends
if you guys don't know your boy trying
to learn spanish i've been living in
los angeles for quite a long time a lot
of my friends are mexican and they speak
spanish
and i want to be a part of that well
guess what when it comes to learning a
language i'm pretty sure you guys
remember being in high school
and not remembering jack [ __ ] well
that's because
they don't teach you languages in school
like how
normal people speak and they don't do it
in a way that allows you to remember
the right way to say things
conversationally speaking things
this is why i love babble babble's 15
minute lessons make it the perfect way
to learn a new language
on the go their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian
and german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation
and accent which is super important to
me because i don't want to just learn
the words i want to know how to
pronounce it as well well right now when
you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use promo
code gb
that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com code gb for an
extra three months
free babble language for
life and it's like and clearly it didn't
really
do anything that dude had his winery
open while everything else was closed
oh for real his own wine and he got a
bunch of
wineries and his and he was indoor
dining with [ __ ] didn't he also
get like
millions of dollars in ppe like the
loans yeah
probably something crazy like three
million dollars does he think that
people won't find this out
like this is all public information he
looks like a piece of [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i don't honestly don't
know what the [ __ ] that these girls are
thinking i'm fighting coming for you
baby
oh come for you give me give me the
promo right now so just cut it cut it
slick
back haired [ __ ] i'm gonna beat
your ass
i thought that was good for you gavin
newsom it sounded like something racist
for a second
you know not respecting hawaii piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] because although some
of the white people the tourists and
i went that encounter in hawaii were
[ __ ] little
like a bunch of hollies huh yeah bro
like so we went to this
we went to maha lulu mahu falls right
and we took like i guess the one of the
entrances and it's like it's a
hawaii is mostly rainforest right and
we're in the jungle pretty much going
through this [ __ ] trail
and the trail's like this big and it's
mud everywhere because it's
the rainforest we come out there's
this this old white dude comes in
he's looking at me and just goes how
long's the trail
like just like that like oh no hello hey
how are you because everyone that we
encountered on the trail they're like oh
is the trail over here i'm like yeah
it's over here everyone's very nice
the one guy with his [ __ ] family of
five comes in and he looks like he's
going to go to like a country club
he's wearing a white polo shirt [ __ ]
some khaki she's just killed him and
left him in the forest
that's why she let the island take him
and he goes how long's the hike
like that like like he was pissed to be
there and i was like it's like 45
minutes
and he doesn't know that i fell on my
ass like eight different times so yeah
boy he's hot i'm like i'm covered in mud
whatever
it was a great hike it was amazing and
he's like is it
muddy look at me and i'm like bro look
down
yeah you're in mud and also do your
[ __ ] research bro you're in hawaii
you're in the [ __ ] jungle have some
[ __ ] respect
yeah you know how many people would want
to be here and they can't be here and
experience this and you're over here
like
a [ __ ] sad [ __ ] about like mud yeah
with a shitty ass attitude like what the
[ __ ]
i don't know what he's expecting he's
like is it muddy you're walking here
it's a hike my guy
yeah you're in the rain forest and and
if you want to look down
if you've ever been a lulu uh
yeah mahu falls like the trail it's it's
so small
and it's covered in like foliage i guess
is the word
nice that's a good word
that was good that was good i like that
you always like kind of culture like
you're getting it you're you're
improving yeah
and and this [ __ ] had the nerves
to be like not even say thank you or bye
and just like
and just like kind of he went ugh no i
made that up to make him sound like more
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] but he was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because
you have a you're in one of the most
beautiful places on earth
and like it's special dude and you go in
here and you're just like
[ __ ] like a south they're mud yeah
i'm like you're outside
here dude go just piece them up right in
the rainbow front of his family and
there's no cameras there so when he
comes out you've been like hey man
[ __ ] hawaiian boar got him dude it
won
me imagine his family's reaction if you
really would have hit him with a
fat one too they would have just started
cheering yeah
oh god that guy was a local guy and i
was like can i be like this
yeah yeah people were throwing shakkas
and i was like babe we got a couple
shotguns today you do when somebody lets
you pass on the road you throw up
bro yeah i let this guy go in and he
went and i was like babe
another one got another shine guys look
at this [ __ ] tourist dude
he just threw up the shot and he threw
it back and what a [ __ ] loser i
didn't throw it back
if people just threw up a burn sign like
this and he goes i must i'd be like
what's up
there's a w in hawaii but like people
throw shotguns
and jeff was like why don't you throw
them back and i was like oh no i don't i
feel like a pony
but yeah i was such a loser how
why is great man like they don't
definitely they have like a huge respect
for for like the land like if you throw
trash on the floor you just believe
something will piece your ass up and
that's what's deserved but see i kind of
like that about hawaii is that
like a fight is very possible oh it's
going to happen it's like
if you don't if you don't tread lightly
or if you're not respectful like
you're going to get in a [ __ ] fight
but that's something everyone's so nice
and welcoming
like there's respect there's like
respect that's what i'm saying there's
like a level of respect anybody knows if
you're if you're from hawaii and you're
listening to this [ __ ] right like hawaii
like i love that place i feel like
everybody's very genuine and
you know they obviously everybody has
like their own cultural problems over
there but i think like
one of the things that i very much liked
is people are not confrontational but
they'll call you out on some [ __ ]
yeah i mean so either you could scrap it
out or you could just
you know just take one to the face you
know either way sure
i was telling nick a story where um
there's this place called hanama bay
right hanauma bay
very touristy spot it's pretty cool even
if it's like a touristy spot it's
still really fun i still love going
there every time um it's like this
little basin where a bunch of fish are
there's like no sharks it's a coral
coral area
um there was a bunch of college kids uh
from some
corn [ __ ] state right i don't know where
the [ __ ] stuff is
where they grow corn and they just [ __ ]
their cups actually
yeah and so they're from corn [ __ ]
university
and they come through and there was like
little old ladies walking around in
hanama bay right and they're obviously
with their families and they were trying
to
do pranks on them like scare them boo
like [ __ ] yell at these old ladies
drown all of them and then you know
these around them and by the way these
guys aren't small they're like from like
a football team or some [ __ ] or rugby
team i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
right kind of loser as [ __ ] is that and
so
you know when they were doing it to this
old asian lady i just remember these
big old moks like moks were like these
big old hawaiian hawaiian guys right
came up to him it's like trying to scrap
bro i was like sup cuz
oh i'm like what what i was like what is
going on and they're like oh no
no we're just [ __ ] having fun he goes
this guy literally
grabs him by his [ __ ] throat like
here and there's like so when you go to
hanama bay
there's rocks and then it just goes deep
into a basin like you fall you die
lily grabs and starts shoving him
towards and this is like him in a bunch
of his homies
and this is with the school and so like
a teacher comes through they're like oh
hold on hold on hold on
he looks at the [ __ ] like the coach
or whatever the teacher i think it was a
coach because
it was like a bunch of just dudes yeah
and he looks at him like he's going to
[ __ ] kill this guy
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
right like the guy's literally [ __ ]
with the locals like throwing trash on
the floor being a bunch of [ __ ] and
these big old moks are like
literally ready to throw down and [ __ ]
everybody up on the team yeah doesn't
matter if you're a football or whatever
they will [ __ ] you up
that same energy bro and i was over
there [ __ ] a mile away going
yeah yeah
that's what i thought [ __ ]
don't mess with my [ __ ] hawaii
that was me but i was realized like yo
this is my hawaii
like people are ready to scrap man you
got to really respect the island and the
people yeah and especially like
i mean it's white people if you've never
experienced racism
come to hawaii we'll give you a good
dose of it absolutely bro and it's
deserved sometimes because some
just some people just don't know how to
like be with the culture you know i mean
like
accept it like when you go to a
different place have an open mind
like like be ready to take in the
culture like the history a little bit
and
i feel like that's really that's the
best way to travel that's what the good
thing about traveling is is like you get
to see
all these different cultures and their
mindsets and and
just like the little things like i think
that's the best part about traveling
and um yeah it's just some of the
[ __ ] don't have that attitude people
like get the [ __ ] out of here then why
are you here you want this to be just
like california wherever the [ __ ] you
came from right
you come here because it's different so
show some [ __ ] respect you know what
i mean
and i'm coming for you gavin newsom
there you go there it is there it is
there it is
some people are just [ __ ] like i was
just you know we were just with khalif
and the place that uh he lives and now
is where i used to live too
but uh there's apparently a new neighbor
that kind of moved in there
and this guy is like the biggest [ __ ]
ever and i've seen him a couple of times
he doesn't really say hi now mind you
people in south pasadena are
very [ __ ] nice like you used to say
hi to your [ __ ] neighbors
and so you know khalif being a really
really nice dude he finally
uh i think he finally said something to
this dude i don't think he just told me
what he said so he
oh before you go up in the place you
have to hit a code before you hit the
gate
uh cliff already hit the code once he
opens the door he sees those neighbors
coming in with him his wife and his
family
and he holds the door open and you know
what this [ __ ] says to him he goes
hey i don't need you to hold open the
door for me and then
khalifa's like all right this is enough
and he looks at his wife he goes okay
would you like me to hold the door for
you ma'am she goes yes thank you very
much
and he holds open the door and then
afterwards like he just kind of
walks up and cleeve looks at him he goes
we're [ __ ] neighbors dude
yeah i mean like yeah have some [ __ ]
self-respect like we're neighbors you
have to see me
right the guy looks at me doesn't say
anything just walks away you know what
khalid should have done what the
he should have went to the guy and
whispered in his ear and says
yeah oh that would have been great long
dick style yeah yeah yeah because khalid
got a long one
long a hundred percent but this guy pure
girth i can't even wrap my fingers
around it so we actually found out
we actually found out through our other
neighbor the guy that lives in front of
us
he used to live in a condo a couple of
ways down in where we live right now
and our buddy across from us his friend
lived in that condo
right and he told me this so he was kind
of venting about how much this dude is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so when he was living there his friend
is actually a cop but in that unit
apparently there's like one outdoor hose
but every unit shares a water bill
for the outdoor hose that's being used
that was just like spraying the water
down or wherever he just left it on and
went back
in and so he's like okay who are these
people well that's what i'm saying and
so he tells him he's like hey and this
guy's a cop
right and he goes hey he's like hey
brother do you mind just you know
turning off the water before you go back
in because we all share the water bill
yeah right and he goes what the [ __ ] are
you the water police oh my god bro
no murder him murder mostly the police
so check this out right so are these
number one people
the corniest response i've ever heard
are you the water police and here's your
clothes the
toilet store water [ __ ]
you love water so much watching mary
so he says that and he goes actually he
goes i'm actually long for i'm an actual
police
officer and he goes [ __ ] you you're just
some [ __ ] civil servant that's what
he says to him
wow [ __ ] police officer dude this guy
that just asked him to
just turn off the water before he goes
inside and that's who this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is
and now i don't even live there anymore
but i'm trying to find out what car he
has so i could keep
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right that
guy has a micro penis
a hundred percent see that's that's why
i like a little dick energy for sure
that's a miserable [ __ ] sucker dude
that's why
like that [ __ ] imagine him at
home he's miserable like
beating his kids and [ __ ] dude he's this
guy let's murder this guy that's why
like
a little bit of that hawaii uh goes
along respect level like that dose of
reality where like you can get your ass
kicked for some [ __ ]
over here in the mainland would be
[ __ ] amazing especially because i
grew up in south pass
and you're right most people in south
pasadena are nice but people in nice
neighborhoods
sometimes they don't they lose touch
with the reality and
and forget that like hey like there's
certain things that you could do that
could still get you [ __ ] up
yeah you know like that's cool in south
pass but you go to
you know any other neighborhood
someone's going to [ __ ]
shoot your face yeah but your ass
they're going to kill you some people
like
i feel like something you do you pull
that [ __ ] on somebody they might kill
you
yeah and rightfully deserve right
yeah you deserve that like somebody
holds open a door for you and then you i
don't need you to hold open my door it's
like
how did you find offense to this is he a
white dude
of course do you think he's racist
but the thing is that that doesn't even
seem real like how are you like that
grinch level of just
miserable he's been he's been a huge
[ __ ] from the get-go because like
i was kind of like the guy in the
complex that was very vocal
right so you know everybody else tends
to be somewhat of a pacifist
but if i have to live there i'm not
going to deal with somebody being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] to me like our last
neighbor before
that's so much dude yeah so that's way
too much our last neighbor he was an
[ __ ] i had a long conversation with
him and he cut that [ __ ] out immediately
so now with this guy it's like well you
guys have to talk to him because he
thinks that it's okay
like at the end of the day for him to
just yell at you for holding
open a door is ridiculous what if it was
like 10 minutes away and khalif was just
holding it there for a little time
i got you and he's been holding and he's
just waiting
for like this i have to rush over so
he's [ __ ] talking to him
that's the part of the story that khalif
left exactly so maybe khalif's the
[ __ ] oh
all right everybody about that twist has
an instagram for his gecko this guy is a
[ __ ] he does he's a pure [ __ ]
he's the sweetest man i've ever met my
gecko instagram
[Music]
yeah it should have been gordon gekko
missed opportunity yeah come on [ __ ]
what an uh supreme [ __ ] that dude is
like what are you i mean like in that as
an adult i always wondered
what am i supposed to do at this point
like do i just break his kneecaps yeah
let's waterboard him
oh you're going because it's crazy
because you know like it's not that bad
right come on
cause i also wonder too like what's
what's his relationship with how is his
wife a [ __ ] [ __ ] too
is his kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] which
is kids are kind of [ __ ] well
for sure i mean they got this guy starts
from the top guiding
guiding
my kids keep getting jumped in south
pasadena and i'm gonna tell him about it
too i think your kids got beat up
yesterday
you guys saw them there was a bunch of
other kids that beat them up
not me and the kids try to lie about to
watch you out and you're like
and they're like but we all know
they just get stitches right kids yes
yes they
do yeah and that's the only valuable
you dude [ __ ] man somebody you know
somebody actually just won uh
a 60 million dollar jackpot again in
canada really [ __ ] asian lady
nice girlfriend just the lottery just
won it so guess how she
found the numbers huh her [ __ ]
husband dreamt of the numbers
no bro see that's some destiny [ __ ] is
real bro
that's an inception bro she's like i
think she's like cambodian or vietnamese
and her husband was just like
a 26 14 12 19. it was the same
guy it was the guy that sang the song it
was testing whatever that
and he woke up and then she [ __ ] won
a 60 million dollar jackpot wow
and that makes me very happy yeah that
makes me very happy good for her
cambodian immigrant do refugee hustle
she wins 60 million dollars because her
[ __ ] husband
dreamt of the [ __ ] numbers what kind
of story is that that's bananas i gotta
get some better dreams bro get some
dreams dawg
what are you dreaming about i don't
remember them really
i haven't been sleeping that well so
maybe that's what's up this game
is the time difference yeah i'm just
getting clubs
i'm just kissing coming up to you and
then she turns to a dude right before
you guys make out and i'm not wake up
confused like gross
yeah you know what i don't really my
dreams are boring
we talk about our dreams a lot too much
with each other what's up with that do
you
i don't think i've ever talked to you
about my dreams everywhere in the last
we did a podcast where we talked about
our dreams did we do it yeah who
remember you he had a dream journal this
[ __ ] okay you know bring some
[ __ ]
guys
dreams are dumb nobody writes their
dreams in their journals dude what the
[ __ ] guys oh [ __ ] man well i actually
told about a dream in the
last podcast when you were gone i
actually had a dream that i was boxing
mike tyson
she was crazy and it was inside the
middle of a casino and he was letting me
light him up oh you know what
i heard this because we were driving to
north shore oh perfect yeah we listened
to this part it was dope
and i was lighting him up mike tyson's
podcast
i would love to meet him but i'm also
scared of him at the same time so i
don't know how i would react i think
he'd be fine
i think you're right david why are you
such a [ __ ]
you hear i hear all these fighting talks
but i you have already have a wet stain
on your pants did you
i come think we need to do the interview
anymore yeah that's exactly i think i
already have mike tyson down pat dude
you got it you got it i [ __ ] love
that guy dude
he's he's he's gonna be bill burr was on
the podcast i know it's kind of awkward
oh really was it well i only watched
like five minutes of it i i didn't watch
the rest of it but it just seemed like a
little a little awkward but interesting
still
yeah yeah but a little weird i feel like
a little doper's the only person that
could do a podcast by himself and get
angry at nothing
yeah and he's so good at it like how
does he do that he gives really good
advice too
he does give really good advice really
good advice but i don't know bro i don't
know how
he's like the perfect angry like he's
just
yeah it like perpetually gets angrier
and angrier and it's
[ __ ] hilarious yeah he's somebody who
could be angry but make you laugh at it
but then also dial it back down like ah
what the [ __ ] do i know i don't know
[ __ ] yeah yeah
you know what i like that because he
doesn't claim to be this guy that like
knows everything but
he does he does play that like yeah i
don't know [ __ ] yeah that's his saving
grace that's how he balances it all he's
like i don't know [ __ ] don't listen to
me blah blah but it's [ __ ] hilarious
but he's usually pretty spot-on
like every time he says something i'm
like yeah i agree with that i like it
right bill
like i know man that guy is a [ __ ]
everybody and their mom now has like a
comedy special it's like
sometimes i wonder because i was just
looking up just
just random people stand up i'm like
these guys
are so much funnier than these [ __ ]
people on netflix
how the [ __ ] is it that they're not
getting an hour special who's your least
favorite special on netflix right now
that you've seen recently i mean there's
a lot dude like it's hard to say
something i think it's over-saturated
yeah you know what somebody who i really
appreciate because of like what she's
done but her stand-up
i i don't think is that great and if i
meet her in person i won't say this to
her face because
i'm just a [ __ ] it's like she's
listening right now like yeah like
tiffany haddish
really i knew you're gonna say that it's
hard listening to her stand up dude
it's like her though it's like dated 90s
like black comedy [ __ ] you know what i
mean like i feel like it's already
evolved past that and she's still
sticking to that 90s comedy
where it doesn't hit anymore and there's
a lot of her just screaming you know
what i'm saying yeah
in the 90s that [ __ ] was [ __ ] mad
funny that's the [ __ ] i used to laugh at
as a kid
but her comedy has not in my personal
opinion hasn't progressed
i think she's dope i'll see her in
whatever movies i think she's a funny
personality
but i want to i watched like two of her
specials and it was just her
saying nonsense i saw her like i saw a
snippet of her stand up on the comedy
uh the comedy store documentary and i
was like yo she's funny as [ __ ] bro i
thought
but it was just a snippet but what she
was really funny in sucks
you must think brendan is a great
stand-up content and he is i haven't
seen that i don't want to
um but i saw her in this movie called
bad trip have you heard this movie
no it's with eric andre and it's like uh
and little rel or something like that
and it's like a hidden camera prank
movie and it's so
well done dude it's so much better than
borat too because it's like it's
produced enough because there's a
storyline that they go through
but the bits that they do are so [ __ ]
funny like have you ever watched eric
andre show it's the best hidden camera
well that's what i'm saying like i like
her in anything but her stand up like
her stand-up's
sometimes really hard to listen to like
there was a there was a moment where cat
williams was going at
[ __ ] uh tiffany haddish in a bunch of
comics because
he said something that was actually very
poignant he goes so tiffany haddish is a
great comic right
tell me one tiffany had his joke and the
room went silent
it's like exactly tell me a tiffany had
a joke
i'm like i kind of see his point right
because people are saying she's an
amazing female comic and i'm like i
actually don't know a single joke that
she has
i just know that i like seeing her in
these movies and she's [ __ ] funny
remember when monique was trying to uh
she was like boycotting netflix because
she didn't get like millions of dollars
for her stand-up special yeah
yeah i mean she definitely couldn't sue
them for that which was a little
ridiculous but also it's like dude
do you really want to watch monique
stand up well here's the thing right
this
i i do understand her point of view
because of of how she was expressing
like the things and how it went down
right
so number one about the process huh well
there's the process and there's like
lower level comics beneath her right you
know at the end of the day monique can
pull numbers
better than these other comics can right
but what they were offering her
was i think to her quote-unquote this is
the rhetoric that they're saying to her
in the meeting you're a legend in this
game there's no other female comic
that's funnier than you
and they give her this [ __ ] paycheck you
know so it's like how much were they
offering or do you remember
it was like i can't don't misquote me on
this but it was definitely not a million
it was like half a million or something
and dave chappelle was offered 40
million you know it's dave chappelle i
understand she was comparing to chris
rock too
okay and she was like well if we're
talking about inactivity dave chappelle
hasn't been anywhere
you know for the longest time so the
inactivity thing doesn't make
i understood her points of view but i
didn't understand why she could sue them
for it but i understand why it was a
little disrespectful i think it was a
pretty low number for her name like even
for me when i heard how much money they
were giving her i was like
that's pretty [ __ ] low sure you know
because her perspective is this
i put out this special that's material i
tour with you have to make up the
numbers for when i tour
you're you have to make up for those
numbers i'm not going to tour this
material now because you already saw it
on the special yeah it's burning
it's burnt now so i think of new [ __ ]
yeah so when i make this when i'm on
tour
i'm making seven figures you have to
offer me the amount that i'm losing
that's just basic [ __ ] yeah which makes
sense that makes sense so like i think
that's the point that a lot of people
were missing because they're like oh
you're no dave chappelle
she's not 100 like dave chappelle he has
an audience that's
dying for his content to come out yeah
right but on her level from a business
perspective
the numbers didn't make sense but for
people to come out and say
monique you need to be grateful grateful
for what she makes seven figures still
touring till this day
and you're asking her to take this deal
that's like 200k 300k or whatever burn
material for burnt material that's
literally not even a quarter what she
makes touring so yeah the numbers don't
make sense but she was trying to sue
them over there the ceiling part is
where it gets a little funky yeah
yeah what's that about well she was
trying to sue i guess she was suing for
like mistreatment or some [ __ ] it's like
that's kind of why that doesn't work
because it's an offer like you can't sue
somebody for offering something you
don't like
yeah right yeah i mean like if i you
know apply to a mcdonald's and they're
offering minimum wage i'm gonna sue your
ass
more than that dude i flip burgers like
a [ __ ] king right right i'm [ __ ]
thinking like six figures at home
flipping burgers yeah
come on dare you have you seen my smash
burgers dude
okay so that was like the biggest issue
with that yeah the whole stand-up comedy
thing like they weren't
it was she was offended by the amount
that they were giving her and it just
logically didn't make sense okay i mean
i can understand that getting offended
there is a lot of comedy is definitely
very saturated on netflix though i mean
and then also with the tiffany haddish
thing like i've only seen a couple bits
and was kind of like oh like okay i was
like all right
like you know where she was i was like
cool no i was just no i was just like oh
that was that was
like it's i can watch certain things and
be like that was funny but i'm not
really laughing out loud
yeah oh that was funny that's a funny
thought whatever that's how the reaction
i had
but there is like a big push especially
because of like our society today for
like women comedians they like really
try to shove women comedians down your
throat
and there are funny women comedians it's
not like that's not possible for sure
but there's like somewhere they'll blow
up like you said tiffany haddish where
it's like they're like
all in because it's like they want to
represent they want to have
representation where it's like
just let it happen naturally it's going
to happen yeah like there are funny
women
and she's definitely just giving time
like it's going to the shit's going to
happen you know
i mean whatever peter dudes and stuff
like that like like i said i'm i'm a fan
of hers but if you're asking me if i
liked her stand up i
did not like it at all it was like the
stuff that i saw that she did back in
like deaf comedy jam
yeah like i've already seen this like
you know i think in anybody else no
matter what art
that you're in we want to see an
evolution of the next [ __ ] yeah some new
material
right and her new material was not new
it's like i've already seen this so
that's why i'm not laughing yeah like
this is already done like you've
you [ __ ] beat this [ __ ] to death
right let's see you do something else
but she does have that ability
so like for her it was it was just kind
of hard like i always go back because
i'm always trying to see what i'm
missing about like brendan's shop all
the time and i'm like i got to see
something here i'ma say something here i
know he's i know he's funny
and i look at him like god damn it this
guy sucks like i i just
i'll fight brenda's shop right now yeah
brandon shop uh david sowell's gonna
beat your ass he will murder me he's a
big he's a big [ __ ] heavyweight
heavyweight
with the tightest pants on earth he
ready to bust out some things
his face is so swollen what's he was he
holding his breath the whole time
because i watch king in this thing all
the time yeah i mean and i'm like
brendan shaw be like dipping in salt
water for three hours a day i watched a
movie called 1917. you remember that
movie
the war movie yeah yeah there's a scene
where the guy one of the main characters
is swimming through
a pile of like dead bodies that have
been floating
in the water for like days that's what
brandon shotgun
wow that is he there you go oh man got
that puff face got that puff face
but always be wearing like [ __ ] weird
ass top hats and [ __ ] like i'm like
bro man that [ __ ] don't work he's trying
some [ __ ] out so me and tiff we uh last
night where we went down
uh we started watching tiger belly and
we watched the episode with carlos macia
and tiffany was not she was yeah she was
not familiar
with what um carlos mencia was known for
right so we watched a bunch of monuments
no we didn't i'm just kidding
uh we watched all the old videos of him
like like stealing jokes and like
creating b for like george lopez and all
that [ __ ]
and on the episode because tiffany was
watching it and she was like
well you know it doesn't sound like what
he did was like that
like she had no like yeah she didn't
understand and then we watched it and
she was like
oh that's very different yeah yeah
that's
bad you know it was she was like that
guy's a narcissist and i was like i
definitely listened to the whole
whole podcast and it was weird because
i think that was supposed to be a moment
for carlos mancia to vindicate himself
dude they were thrown them lobs
they were literal and he just kept on
[ __ ] not seeing [ __ ] going to his
face and he was like slip
no take this lob he's like it's like
rape and it was like
when he made that rape reference yeah
i'm like hey man slow it down by
comparing stealing jokes to rape yeah
yeah and i was like oh
he was trying to make it he was trying
to be very poignant
i take this stuff seriously it's like
rape and i'm like
yikes so you're obviously raping people
down
death you are yeah this is me sleeve is
cutting off circulation yeah
oh my god your toes are purple yeah yeah
this is actually not a sock it's
actually my foot
i couldn't watch it bro i saw the
thumbnail and i was like i can't watch
it there was a there was a
comedy special i forgot what the [ __ ]
it's called but it was uh
a few years ago and they interviewed but
it was just about stand up and they
interviewed comics or whatever and they
had him on the
on the show or whatever and there's a
snippet where they're like they address
they go ask them like hey were you
stealing jokes
and he like goes he's like yeah i was
stealing jokes like don't do your best
jokes around and he was like trying to
be funny about it but he was just
admitting
he's like yeah don't bring your best
bits around me i'll steal that [ __ ] like
yeah what the [ __ ] and it was just kind
of weird and it was like a
two minute like or minute minute some
change
it was just kind of like wait what he
craved himself up yeah it was just weird
he crammed the [ __ ] out and just
admitted that he jacked all these jokes
and it was like wait what it was [ __ ]
whack as [ __ ]
yeah it's very odd when because when i
was watching it like i think
bobby was trying to humanize him a
little bit right so there was a lot of
funny stories that they had when they
went to honduras and all this other [ __ ]
which i thought it was really dope like
getting to see this like more
other side of them yeah yeah and then
when it came to the hard question
which i think bobby was actually trying
to lob him something real easy
was just for him to just apologize on
the public forums like yeah i stole
these jokes whether i thought i did it
or not it affected people in a negative
way
but i did understand i mean because i
mean he is
seems very narcissistic um i think in
his mind
and in hearts of hearts he really thinks
he didn't steal [ __ ]
so for him he's like if i stole
something specifically from a specific
human being
i want to apologize to them face to face
in person to that person that i stole
but right now i'm being accused of
general things
but there's no way for me to direct this
apology so i want to direct this apology
to the person you need to talk to me and
then yo
i'll apologize to you face to face if i
stole your joke but
everybody's just saying i heard you
stole jokes but nobody's telling me
specifically what it is
so it's like aside from the big bits
like the cosby bit and whatever
which was which was the same [ __ ] it
was literally bit
for bit there was no change yeah
which like for that too the reason why
that that bit is kind of hard to say it
was like similar mentality
because the delivery was the same
exactly so that's where people get
caught if the delivery is the same
then we kind of have an issue right
because i've also had a situation
where i've had bits that sounded very
very similar to somebody else but you
stopped doing them
i just stopped doing them i was like ah
they did it funnier than me and it's
very similar so i'm like
[ __ ] it we'll just leave it alone and
that happens like you can because it's
there's certain ideas where you're like
that's funny and other people can think
of the same [ __ ] that happens all the
time where you're like
my best you have to decide who got to it
first and that's dude my best friend
knows this [ __ ] too when we watch that
chappelle [ __ ]
i'm not saying i'm chappelle you know
what i'm saying yeah but i literally
wrote this stand-up stand-up bit which
was uh
dave chappelle talking about how
sometimes like you're a bigger
comedian than you are a human being is
when he was talking about uh that
uh not not uh corona [ __ ] it was um
talked about kramer that he he mentioned
that with kramer oh yeah yeah so it was
like a bit like i literally wrote
something
hyper similar to it i'm like but am i
gonna take that material and do it after
dave chappelle right
absolutely not absolutely people do it
now yeah i'll do it right now hey guys
so you know sometimes you'll be a
comedian
voice yeah you know what i mean but like
yeah dave chappelle made a joke about
the the [ __ ] uh
the kung flu joke yeah right i had me i
was literally talking about that with my
best friend and i wrote into a bit
and he texted me he goes bro like dave
chappelle did
your joke i was like we didn't do my
joke but he was like that was the joke
that you made i was like
i know i'm getting close to him yeah i
was like
david we did it a similar joke i almost
felt proud like oh i'm
something on the same wavelength we're
in the same page i read mine i was like
this is not that funny i just started
scribbling it out but it was
but those things happened so i i
understand what people say
there's concepts and thoughts that are
very [ __ ] similar there's gonna be a
lot of asian comics that i'll see
that'll do [ __ ] that i've done
on this podcast yeah or i've done like
in previous videos
but i'm like yeah yeah the fangirl shout
out but like i'll see it and i'm like ah
but
they're also asian american they
probably grew up in a similar experience
so
maybe they didn't steal it and there's
this gray area that happens
the car has been seen yeah called
mancinia and
cosby bit was stolen there is absolutely
no
[ __ ] way it was not stolen 100
percent yeah it's
like he does it so much like some of amy
schumer's bits
amy schumer's are bad yeah they're
pretty bad i saw some of them where it
was kind of a reach
you know i mean i'm like that's actually
pretty common i've heard many comics do
this joke yeah you know i mean
and her delivery was different so now
you guys are reaching yeah but there was
a few
that were just like okay this is clearly
but she has like two whole like
20-minute
compilations of like people putting
those out you know
yeah her latest special was really bad
like i uh was was that the one where
she's pregnant yeah
yeah oh she's pregnant and it made me
feel like oh she had to be very careful
of like stealing
jokes so she had trouble like forming
these jokes they were like half ideas
i'm like because as much as people want
to hate on amy schumer before i knew she
stole those jokes i actually thought she
was a pretty dope comic
like straight up i'm like oh these i
could see why people would think this is
funny it didn't make me laugh but i'm
like oh i thought she was pretty dope
and then i found a half that [ __ ] stolen
so i'm like no wonder
yeah you know well at the same time okay
so when people are like oh amy schumer's
completely not funny i was like well if
she's not funny
but she stole these very successful
jokes which one is it yeah that's like
no she is funny yes but she's funny with
other people's material yeah yeah you
know that's what it is so there's a
duality to that
right and that's the thing too it's like
if if it is such a common thing
like what like carlos macia was saying
like oh yeah like we all come up with
jokes at the same time if that was such
a common thing that would happen
all the time but it doesn't because
every comedian is like
similar i'm going to stop it yeah
exactly guys notice
it's over yeah because i want to be that
guy yeah right because he was just like
don't you just make a blanket apology
and then you could deal with the
personal people that you stole from
later
because people are i think there's
people on his side that are waiting for
him to apologize
so they can forgive him yeah they're
waiting for that moment right because
let's let's be real mindemencio was a
[ __ ] funny show i used to love that
show
crack the [ __ ] up watching that show i
remember remember when he was at the
border
and then like he was like trying to get
the the board of guy to say some racist
[ __ ]
and he was like hey who comes like
wetbacks right he goes like
he goes yeah went back he goes what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] up you know what i
mean so he had like really funny moments
yeah so when when you like discredit
some of these guys for not being
funny at all you're being disingenuous
right like this he would have made it
that far
exactly he's definitely funny yeah but
he was jacking people's [ __ ] [ __ ]
which that's not cool at all and that's
some weird mental gymnastics to be like
everybody knows i've done this but like
i'm not gonna do a public apology like
i'd rather do it to them face to face
yeah that's some weird what are you
saying like i understand i think for him
because he genuinely believes he didn't
steal anything
so he wants so that's why he was making
the the rape accusation like
that's like everybody saying that i'm
raping people but there's not a single
person coming forward
that's a victim so like oh i was like oh
like bad analogy i don't compare things
to rape most of the time
yeah let's let's not do that but he is a
pretty big narcissist man
he was almost on the podcast he was like
almost trying to ask people for credit
like yeah i'm the reason why
like i used to put you up at this point
it's weird when you
because i never really i've only i've
met a few narcissists in my life but
before that i was
you always hear the word people are
narcissistic narcissists but when you
meet an actual narcissist it's
really [ __ ] weird they make you feel
like you're crazy and also yeah you
i was almost kind of like confused like
it's confusing like
wait what what's happening here it takes
a second to like really understand
like wait actually oh no this dude's out
of his mind until after the conversation
because it's like after the interaction
yeah because it doesn't seem like people
could actually be like that yeah and
then you're like wait
oh [ __ ] no this was just a [ __ ]
narcissist he's out of his mind that's
the thing that like
narcissists do is that they'll throw all
this like they'll do good things for you
just so they could say they did it i did
something yes dude
like i've dealt with that was someone
very close to me and it was like what
the
[ __ ] is that about like that's so weird
and they're just constantly
like yeah i did this i did this i did
this and i'm like okay but that's not
what we're talking about
we're talking about something completely
different but for you to like throw that
back in my face it's like what's the
point of that like
right we might as well just say random
things if we're just saying oh yeah i
i like it when you sneezed yesterday i
said god bless you did your spirit fly
out of your body
help me out right now
laugh afterwards it's very odd like
listening to him defend himself
knowing that he's not going to win this
argument like but in his mind he's like
i'm killing it he's like i refuse
because i'm right killing it
killing it i i just it just it was hard
like they would never know
they'll never know doug he's aged quite
well he just looks like carlos macia
from back in the day
he looks the same he looks exactly the
same exactly the same bro but
but that's such a death scent as a comic
though like once it's like you're
a joke thief that's a wrap you know
what's weird too a lot of people to like
i think in the comic world like stealing
jokes is a huge thing right
but some of these kids now they still
jokes all the time and they think that
it's okay
like stand up wise or like for tickets
content whatever they just steal these
contents and they're just like
oh we're just trying to make people
laugh yeah but that's not the
[ __ ] prank guys oh god there's that
is the
lowest form of [ __ ] comedy the prank
couples
oh my god babe why'd you put the dildo
on the stool now my ass is bleeding like
it's like
the worst acting in the way my
boyfriend's going to come in
and i'm going to be in the bed with this
guy but he doesn't know
that i'm playing him
and then he comes yo what the [ __ ] is
this what the [ __ ] is that bad
bad bad bad it's a prank i think he goes
like oh
oh my god he leaves the room i have no
idea the red thought with a camera
or the guys [ __ ] up or the guys that go
into [ __ ] like walmart and they just
[ __ ] with people trying to do their
groceries oh the the moaning guy dude
oh bro that i don't know what's not mean
but hit him with a car
you know yeah because why are you doing
that people are just trying to buy
[ __ ] groceries dude during a pandemic
it's already stressful enough yeah
and you're over here i saw one this guy
was like making out with this girl on
this guy
and it's like that guy deserves to punch
you in the face yeah if he did it would
be okay
yeah like not against the law and it's
like it's so
i don't know why it's funny i don't know
who it's funny too because
one of the guys that go to walmart and
they just knock [ __ ] over it's a prank
all you gotta do is shoot them in the
legs when they're blowing their kneecaps
you just need to crawl out punch the
girl in the back of her head so
she could smash her teeth into his head
yeah two for one special
dude and at that case it's okay because
why the [ __ ] are you doing that
and then on top of that filming it and
being
like putting it on youtube well
low-hanging fruit comedy is like the
[ __ ] right now
it is i guess right it's like it's
almost sad because i'm watching this i'm
like who the [ __ ] is laughing at this
obvious joke
yeah like there's no there's nothing to
this joke
like it's like a joke a three-year-old
can make like all the vine ones black
people are like this
white people are like you know it's like
oh [ __ ] off bro i'm kind of
shout out to jason chen dude
oh that fool's [ __ ] hey videos are
terrible
he's doing the algorithm jason i love
you but [ __ ] man i'm definitely not your
friend anymore but you know what's crazy
that [ __ ] still like
pops off it's crazy it pops off they're
like oh my god this is so true
i'm like what is true and you're like
what's going on
yeah and i kill myself and i'm pretty
much you tell jason
yeah i'm just a tiny man trying to make
a big dollar bill he's like he's like
but have you bought bitcoin yet and i'm
like yes i have
yes i have i got it he's like then shut
the [ __ ] up yes sir
when i watch jason's videos i literally
just want to go over to his house and
break his legs
we know where he lives let's go let's go
he's probably going to do a chinese new
year
and just kiss him in the mouth because
we're still friends like [ __ ]
frank because frank we i bring him he's
a buddy of mine and
i bring him to train with like jason
sometimes and he's like
and today he dropped me off at the house
and he goes i was like oh i'm gonna
train jason tomorrow he goes
okay because he'll send me his videos if
you like i didn't think jason
like made these videos he had no idea
and like he looks like hates him
he's like disgusting [ __ ] ass it's so
funny because like every adult friend
like they look at this they go you know
this guy i'm like no
absolutely not i'm talking about i love
jason but content-wise
not my cup of tea that's all yeah not my
cup of loser tea
shout out to jason chen lukewarm oolong
tea i love you very much man you're the
carlos mencia of continental music
no but jason is a very kind soul
that feels so buff dude it's crazy
though like how
like think about like everyone's like
when you cough
everyone has to be like hey yo theo boss
said it the best man coffee is a new n
word
somebody really is like whoa whoa whoa
whoa
yeah bro i was at the gym the other day
and uh i drank some water
and you know when you breathe out of
your mouth you tend to choke on water
sometimes yeah
just normal functions i choked on my
water and this guy
looked at me like he was gonna [ __ ]
like
like i had well you know i had the china
virus that's exactly how he looked at
and then i was like i missed trump yeah
i know yeah bring it back
let's bring him back for like a guest
you can't you can't go on twitter
facebook nothing
no yeah what does it like to be banned
like that yeah he's banned exiled
yeah what does he do you go on youtube
though right he's going crazy i think
that's all connected google youtube
whatever he can't do anything
he happens
he'd have a vicious zanga dude he's just
grabbing super emotional
[ __ ] haiku [ __ ] haikus baby
i love [ __ ] i'm glad we're not gonna
have to hear about him too much anymore
yeah i'm just getting
out of here like yeah we get it he's a
[ __ ] douchebag whatever all right
next
it's like where are you going next huh
who'd you vote for this last year
she's actually seems pretty she's kind
of i think everybody loves tulsi gabbard
she's pretty dope he's pretty cool she
seems like
yeah reasonable good leader seems like
yeah i'm worried voting for jacques
that's what i'm going for i voted for
joe jorgensen
who the [ __ ] is that i don't know i
don't know
[Laughter]
i didn't know what it was i took this
election very seriously joe jorgensen
i voted for joe jorgensen afterwards
left the election went to my buddy's
house
i was like i voted for some dude named
joe jorgensen and someone was like
that's a woman
yeah i was like what what the [ __ ] huh
you go back and you rip up the ballot
box you're like god damn it this mail
joe jorgensen sounds really powerful
yeah he seems like a rural that's a good
name
dude joe jorgensen that's some wwe [ __ ]
right there brother
you're a sexist dude dudley brothers
[ __ ] right there brother
that's a [ __ ] bro 3-d
ddt dude
that thought that wrestling was like
real yeah yeah i used to get mad
i used to try to fight like if people
told me it wasn't real i would like try
to fight them yeah why how did we get
duped like that yeah
i don't know but i legit thought it was
real do you want to hear one of the most
embarrassing stories i would love to and
better i'm better
pregnant if he's right you're pregnant
i remember you staying in sacramento
what are you doing dog uh i
i got in a fight with this dude and when
i was in like seventh grade because
his name was bob was mexican dude and i
just wanted to bob the mexican that's
hilarious i'll do it next time and we'll
be like bob the builder
they would make those jokes because
we're all [ __ ] he's like no it's bob
the mexican
yeah bob the mexican he was actually a
really nice guy i don't know why like
roberto but whatever loki i think people
were racist to him because he was a
mexican dude like he was one of the few
mexican dudes
at the the christian school i went to
for like a year two years it was awful
um but i got in a fight with this dude
why why
why'd you fight him i forgot it was like
he's he called me like a chick or some
[ __ ] oh that'll
do it yeah that's pretty bad that's like
that's like the second time that'll
start it
i got if i was other dude calling me a
chick too and yeah i got in trouble
anyway so
uh i i wanted to [ __ ] like beat his
ass and i i forgot what happened but all
i remember was like we kind of scuffled
a little bit
and then i was in seventh grade and i
literally thought
sean michaels the hbk heartbreak kid oh
dude just saying it just makes me
[ __ ] like
i tuned up the band bro and he goes you
watch wrestling and i'm like
yeah do you and he goes yeah
he's like shawn michaels and i'm like
yeah and then we stopped fighting and we
became friends
isn't that the [ __ ] lamest thing
you've ever heard
sean michaels kick him and i was gonna
super kick him you were so the fight
the player was tuning up the band you
were squared up and you were like
i was like [ __ ] and i was like
you're gonna hit him with the sweet chin
music
is the sorriest story that i've ever
heard in my life and i regret it you
guys
literally were going to scrap and he saw
you know we were we were fighting
already
and like i i think you had your ultimate
move right yeah i was ready to go well
it's coming right now
because are you doing the music did you
go ah
i
shawn michaels and but that's the thing
hbk wouldn't it be nice
okay
we're like you both we we both watch
wrestling and then we're like
wait a second burrito is like a bigger
egg roll
i guess we have more similarities than
differences
we friends
fizzled out after that was that the end
of it that was that was the peak and
then that was it and then we didn't
really talk about it bro
but my homie kenny i talk about him a
lot one for one of his mma fights he
came out to hbk
oh that's amazing what that's a great
[ __ ] song to come out to shout out to
kenny
on his newborn child yeah kenny's a papa
dude yo kenny's like
yo people mess dm me randomly and
they're like are you kenny from
geniusbrain and he goes nah
wrong guy i'll kill you he goes don't
you ever hit me up again don't you ever
disrespect me ever again
why you always talking about me in the
podcast i'm like [ __ ] you love it i
love kenny bro
he's the best we always talk about at
least once just know that when you spar
kenny
hit him very lightly yes because the
moments he tastes a little blood in the
water
you are [ __ ] yeah and i always tell
him like kenny
be gentle please yeah and he goes of
course that he's super gentle he's nice
with you
but then when i say about some other
people i'm like well you shouldn't have
hit him so hard he's gonna hit you back
yeah you [ __ ]
i always warm him up before i try to be
like really nice make him laugh a lot
right before like uh all right it's all
fun i already know kenny let's hit him
sometimes too i'm like can you let me
hit you yeah
when he likes you he's too nice to you
and you're like what the [ __ ] is your
deal
he's actually a really good like coach
too like he picks apart what you're
doing and he'll
this feels so funny he's like hey next
time do this and that i'm like what's
that kenny he goes
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
like kenny no i want to know tell me if
you tell me please tell me the secrets
he goes no i don't know what i'm doing
his daughter's gonna be a little beast
oh for sure she's killing everybody oh
yeah
he's like she's going to be the next
marv marina [ __ ] and i'm like oh [ __ ]
who's that
who the hell is this you guys don't know
about todd and marv
are you just making [ __ ] up right now so
these guys
marinovich brothers actually trained bj
penn they're the guys that trained bj
when he fought diego sanchez and like
that's when he had his resurgence oh
so he is a very famous story i think his
son's name was todd marinovich
and he trained him like when he was a
baby like he wouldn't make him across
the football field
like super intense like they did espn 30
for 30.
and it's actually a very fascinating
story but he would over train his kid
like for excellence
super hard and like every day he was
just such a hard dad and
he was like legendary for how hard he
trained his kid and his kid was a
todd marinovich became like a really
good like an
amazing quarterback went to usc was
going to go to
the pros but then so much pressure hit
him where he just was like i don't want
to play football anymore i just like he
started [ __ ] chicks
he had like a spiral you know like and
he just was like may [ __ ] football even
though he was like
the next tom brady or some [ __ ] yeah and
he gave it all away
became a surfer and was like i'm done
with it yeah and he doesn't talk to his
dad anymore something like that yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's gonna
be kenny ruiner yeah great
wanna release your relationship with
your kid yeah yeah dad beat father kenny
hey man that's your future that's you
over you know
over achieving father yeah you know he
expects excellence
he's going to make his baby [ __ ] run
miles when she's
when she's right i wonder what kind of
dad you would be like i don't know if
you'd be kind of strict or would you be
more like that fun goofy dad
i think you'd be fun goofy did yeah i
can't see you being strict as [ __ ]
you know i think you know if we do have
a kid i think tiff is going to be a
pushover with the with the baby
and i think i'll have to be like the the
disciplinarian i'm like
no son you can't do that i'll talk like
that
yeah that's how that's how i would be
i'd be all right just like
if i was your child i would never
respect you every son
wear this shirt it has nte
wrong where's the s dad
ja wrong and he's like what they cut
yourself just like my friends
idiot [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah dude i
don't know about having a kid any time
soon though everyone keeps asking us
like cause after you get married they're
like when are you gonna have a baby yeah
no take your time
it's like [ __ ] dude are you going to
instruct an 80s jazzercise class
your [ __ ] socks you loser dude wait
till the shorts come off
who's ready to sweat
i think that's how that's my new niche
that's when you're good bro once corona
is gone your boy's going to be doing
that yeah you're neon
we pick on [ __ ] david bro again you
know
hey uh red red shorts huh
hey you got him on that got him on that
one hey hey fix your drawstring [ __ ]
jerk
damn
i gotta do some fireworks boom boom boom
boom he he still got him he's doing some
jabs
he wasn't an actual kickboxer was he
really an actor he was an actual
professional kickboxer he got a sixth
spinning back kick i think yeah does he
spinning i think he had a pretty good
winning record too like
it's not like one or two he has like 20
fights who is he like who was was that
like
chuck norris was fighting yeah right
yeah
i forgot who i don't know who was
backing them up they're like uh like you
guys don't know like billy oh
michael j white he's like billy blanks
can [ __ ] fight like he's not some
some just a guy he just took his [ __ ]
and made a [ __ ] ton of money off of it
for him yeah so don't [ __ ] with billy
blind blank spot when he was throwing
those
jabs in that commercial i was like they
were not they were like pistons
yeah it was fast i was like oh [ __ ]
firecrackers i'm going billy
white that dude is a scary [ __ ] too like
six foot five or some [ __ ] is he really
that big he's
way taller than me holy [ __ ]
nobody thinks michael jack white can
fight that dude can fight
[ __ ] have you seen black
dynamite that dude's throwing means
kicks in that movie he's really sick
right i love that forever
yeah i watched black dynamite for the
first time two years ago
i almost peed laughing i didn't watch my
hair it was so
funny i didn't know i didn't understand
like at first i thought i was like okay
it's a black exploitation film
then i didn't underst i didn't get that
they were parodying it and then
i was because i was high when i was
watching it then i figured it out
funniest [ __ ] movie i've ever seen in
my life dude that movie is hilarious
there's these funny [ __ ] moments
because he's also a
[ __ ] pimp in there there's like this
girl's like
hey daddy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
yeah with the hangers yeah and it like
zooms in on his face and he's like
you know what the saddest thing is that
is actually michael jack white's best
film
really black it's so good he's a comedic
genius it is
that [ __ ] funny it's really good dude
everyone talks about all the time it's
[ __ ] good it is like the uh black
american version of [ __ ] nacho libre
yeah
exactly yeah i mean it's a high movie
too if you don't want to
smoke a little bit then you watch it on
netflix bro is it it's it's on netflix
it's good
that's really [ __ ] good well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
uh make sure that you guys watch black
dynamite
and we have nick the ear right you could
find
uh nt trung and detroit yeah yeah he's
gonna change that logo though for sure
yeah it was just it was just a it was
like a prototype it was not a prototype
he actually printed a hundred shirts
i you know i only i always only print
like 10 shirts at a time
and it's like supreme model you know
it's like 100 you printed a hundred
shirts and you thought you're gonna sell
them
can we cut this out no we cannot and
then you can find patrick
patrick.t.riley and we will see you all
next time i'm giving these away
these are my prototypes guys